>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Mary Beth Riedner: I'd like
to thank the Library of Congress
and David M. Rubenstein for
selecting Tales and Travels
as one of the 2017 Best
Practices Honorees.
I'm here on behalf of the
Gail Borden Public Library
in Elgin, Illinois.
And also present in the audience
is Karen Mackey[Phonetic],
who is the former Deputy
Director at Gail Borden,
who's belief in this idea
helped turn it into a reality.
This morning, we are
hearing about a lot
of wonderful literacy programs
for children, and for adults
who never learned to read.
Our focus is on the end
of the age spectrum.
For those stricken with
Alzheimer's disease
or related dementia in the
last years of their lives.
And there are over 5 million
such people in our
country today.
Our society still attaches
a stigma to dementia,
we tend to focus on
the losses instead
of what people can still do.
So, reading is a skill that's
been assumed to be lost,
but that is a misconception.
Research bears this out.
Professor Michelle S
Bourgeois from the University
of South Florida states, "All
of my research demonstrates
that people who were literate
maintain their ability to read
until the end stages
of dementia."
In 2007, the International
Federation
of Library Associations
published their guidelines
for library services to
persons with dementia.
And they advocate
for the use of books
and reading with
this population.
I developed the Tales &
Travels program in 2008
after my own husband
was diagnosed
with a young onset dementia.
I learned that each person
with dementia is still
a unique individual
with their own interests
and abilities.
Every time we bring
Tales & Travels
to a new facility we tend
to get the same response
from staff like, I didn't
know that Martha could read."
Or, "I'm amazed that that they
stayed for the full hour."
Assuming that they can no
longer read, no one puts books
into their hands, or
invites them to read.
So, that's where Tales &
Travel can make a difference.
So, how does it work?
Each month we take participants
on a one-hour imaginary trip
to another country or region
in the United States
using library materials.
We invite them to take
turns reading out loud
from a folk tale, myth or
legend from the chosen location.
We often take them
from children's --
oh, I went too far.
Go back. There we go.
We often take them from a
children's folk tale collection.
So, we retype them in large font
to make them easier to read,
and also to maintain
their dignity
as others have mentioned.
Those who don't choose to
read usually follow along
with the printed text
or they listen quietly.
We also give then five
interesting facts, inviting them
to read these out loud as well.
And we often hear comments
from the participants such as,
"I didn't know that", or
"Isn't' that amazing?"
We then distribute
carefully selected adults
and children's books for
them to browse through.
From the adult collection,
we take travel books
and coffee table books
that are richly illustrated
with color photographs.
But, we also bring in
related books on the history
of the areas, the art and
architecture, or cooking.
Children's books are readily
accepted, when they are chosen
to respect the dignity
of this adult audience.
Simple vocabulary and lots
of white space make these books
attractive, especially to those
in the later stages
of the disease.
We do have some samples of
the books in the back row
for you to take a look at.
As they browse, the
library staff
and volunteers circulate among
the participants engaging them
in conversation.
They often want to talk about
memories from their own lives
that are stimulated by
the book's contents.
This type of socialization is
an extremely important part
of the program.
Tales & Travel received a Target
Grant from the National Network
of Libraries and Medicine
to study the effectiveness
of the program.
The study shows really high
ratings for the overall success
as you can see in this chart.
Other results include
increased cognitive
and social interaction,
improved relationships
between individuals with
dementia and their caregivers,
and a lessening of
stigma about people
with dementia among
the volunteers.
So, encouraging literacy
opportunities
with this too often
forgotten group of people can,
and does improve the
quality of their lives.
The Gail Borden Library
received a free tool --
oh, I'm sorry, provides
a free toolkit
on its Tales & Travel website
to help others replicate
the program.
Feel free to contact
me or Glenna Godinksky,
her contact information
is there,
with more questions or comments.
It's our hope that this
recognition will inspire
librarians and others, including
you, to find additional ways
to make sure that
the gift of books
and reading remains an
intrical part of the lives
of those living with dementia.
Thank you for this attention,
and for this wonderful honor.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.